big thanks to kingdom maker for
sponsoring this video have you ever
looked out your window and thought golly
i wish the world was mine to command
well i'm here to tell you that it is
introducing kingdom maker the fantasy
mobile game that lets you truly take
control of your own world and produce
all manner of mayhem to your heart's
content the game combines elements from
real-time strategy role-playing and
simulation games to form a completely
new experience where you can not only
customize everything about your kingdom
from its placement to its appearance but
also create unique champions that look
exactly how you want them to and level
them up isn't he a looker fight for more
territory to expand your kingdom the
only limit to how far you can go is your
mind
and you can use your customized nobles
to research or explore dungeons or trade
or even make babies with one another
which i personally think is one of the
coolest parts about the game if you want
to take control of your very own kingdom
and explore dungeons and build your city
and form alliances and make babies then
follow my link in the description below
to download kingdom maker for free on
your ios or android device that's right
kingdom maker is completely free on any
ios or android device so click the link
in the description and start making
those babies today and now on to the
video
if nintendo game franchises were
infinity stones then i would be thanos
because i love them all fortunately they
all come with quite the fair share of
easter eggs and sometimes the odd
mystery some of which have been solved
over the years and some of which have
yet to be solved my fellow gamers behold
i have assembled the top 10 list of
unsolved mysteries in nintendo games
from yours truly bandit games let us
begin number 10 how was new donk city
from super mario odyssey founded some
people claim that this isn't a mystery
at all since it obviously was founded
after mario defeated donkey kong and
pauline took over as mayor in that very
spot right hence all the familiar red
bars everywhere and i agree about the
location but i'm talking about who
founded the city not where or when see
there are very obvious donkey kong isms
present everywhere you've got streets
named after cranky kong and dixie kong
and stores named banana bagels and
expresso espresso which are all pretty
deep references for donkey kong fans it
also means that the city was probably
made by and at least temporarily
governed by donkey kong himself hence
all the references or perhaps by a fan
of donkey kong from inside the mario
universe which is pretty unlikely to be
pauline herself because of the whole you
know kidnapping thing so unless she's a
closet victim of stockholm syndrome and
just had to make a city dedicated to her
kidnapper i'd say whoever founded new
dunk city is still a mystery number nine
breath of the wild's timeline placement
long-time fans of the legend of zelda
know that trying to understand the
canonical timeline of the series is
about as easy as playing one of those
cheating games at a carnival you think
you're gonna get it but you never
actually get it and if your friend says
you got it don't believe them they're
lying matters were only made worse when
breath of the wild released and it got a
timeline placement kind of at the end of
all three timelines with no definite
connection to any one of them which
doesn't make any sense because there are
three timelines that it could be
connected to this is frustrating to say
the least and it spawned countless
theories over the years some of which
i've even come up with that try to
explain how the sea salt proves it's in
the adult timeline or zelda's mention of
the twilight proves it's in the child
timeline or the existence of lionels
proves it's in the fallen timeline or a
combination of all three somehow to this
day and until we find a better solution
from the word of god nintendo themselves
it will remain a mystery fit to be
solved only by fan theories number eight
who actually is bowser's mom okay i know
everyone and their dog knows about this
mystery and how haha it's so funny that
peach could actually be bowser junior's
mom he isn't that such an edgy theory
but to be honest it's about the best
guess out there that anyone's actually
come up with to this day babies do
indeed come from you know
mothers however there is a semi-deep
lore theory that could explain this one
see babies in the mario universe have
been shown to be delivered by storks in
the yoshi's island games and also in the
super mario brothers show for the
gorilla couple named june and ward which
could mean that bowser jr came from
nobody but see this is still just a fan
theory and hasn't been confirmed in any
of the games so until we see the little
evil turtle boy being carried into town
in the mouth of a stork this will remain
unsolved number seven are link and zelda
related you know familially in the
original two games link and zoda are
definitely implied to share some face
sucking action after the curtain falls
at the end of the game and i apologize
greatly for using that term which would
obviously imply that they are not
related obviously however lots of fans
of the series decided they actually were
siblings or otherwise related when a
link to the past released and link's
uncle says to link that zelda is your
dot dot dot and then kicks the bucket
before finishing his sentence annoyingly
this was strengthened further in ocarina
of time when link and zelda were
designed to look extremely similar to
one another and link gains access to
stuff that only the royal family should
have access to and the list goes on but
then skyward sword released and
showcased a pretty obvious z-link
romantic connection between the two so i
digress the fanbase seems to be split
between those on the side of them being
siblings or cousins and those on the
side of them not being siblings you know
so that they can become related if you
catch my drift a mystery to this day
number six where are peach's parents see
we know they exist for several in-game
in-universe reasons such as the fact
that the original booklet for the
original super mario brothers game
mentions them directly and the mushroom
king as princess toadstool's father
makes another appearance in the super
mario comics although that one might not
be considered canon either way though
it's definitely odd that peach is still
known in game as you know a princess
implying that her parents are still out
there somewhere as the king and queen
who knows maybe their castle and their
cake is even bigger than peaches the
world may never know numero cinco why
why on the goddess's green earth is
there a ghost hand in the toilet that
makes multiple appearances across the
zelda series seriously from a lore
standpoint and a writing standpoint why
who comes up with stuff like this
actually nintendo had a bit of real life
help on this one and no it's not some
crazy story about nintendo headquarters
according to miyamoto himself the
ghostly hand coming out of the toilet is
a reference to the japanese ghost story
about well uh hand gramming you from
deonanda as you try to
relieve yourself yeah i bet we're all
feeling real comfortable right now as
far as an in-universe explanation goes
though there isn't much and that goes
for every time these hands appear in the
toilets across different games as
different characters is it always the
ghost of someone who died using the
bathroom is the rest of their body down
there it's creepy it's mysterious we're
moving on number four have you ever
owned a copy of the gameboy camera the
camera attachment game for your game boy
don't lie i know you didn't well the
game functions pretty much as expected
it's a camera you take selfies with it
of your face or perhaps of your dog it's
a bit quirky in the fact that the actual
camera mode is stylized to look like an
rpg perhaps even like pokemon perhaps
even because it was co-developed by game
freak and because of this they included
the seemingly useless run option on the
camera rpg control screen when you
select it normally it takes you to a
picture of some area of the world i
don't know why like i said it's kind of
quirky however every now and then when
you press run a very unsettling face
will pop up and ask you what are you
running from there are multiple possible
faces that pop up and more even creepier
faces in the japanese version and if
this isn't nightmare fuel especially for
young children i don't know what is and
to make matters worse we still don't
know who these faces belong to or why
they pop up in the game asking children
who they're running from my answer is
that face i'm running from that face
number three what actually is the fierce
deity see at the end of majora's mask if
you were a good player and collected all
of the masks in the game you can trade
them all to a moon child in exchange for
one particular very powerful
transformative mask called the fierce
deity mask which when equipped turns
little ink into what looks to be big
link from ocarina of time just plus 200
badass points and a giant freaking sword
the thing is since the other
transforming masks in the game were all
created from the captured spirits of
their actual living beings which is why
link transforms after putting the masks
on one has to wonder where exactly or
should i say who exactly the fierce
deity mask originates from again there
have been no shortage of theories on the
matter from fans trying to pin the
mask's origin on the deceased people of
terminal or maybe even the spirit of us
the players ourselves but alas no actual
answer has been reached and the entire
mystery behind the fierce deity lingers
to this day number two getting close now
who and what and why and just what the
hell is going on with this mysterious
caged green swamp in mario kart 64. some
of you astute fans out there who used to
play the game or maybe even still doing
the nintendo 64 online will probably
recall the course known as bowser's
castle in this course once you enter the
castle and turn right into the first
long corridor you can see way down at
the end this imprisoned green thwomp
just staring back at you now in the
remake of this level from mario kart wii
the thwomp is no longer shown as being
green so we're not sure if it was just
the lighting in the original game making
it green or what but that's not the
point the point is what the heck did the
swamp even do for bowser of all people
to straight up imprison it inside the
castle it even laughs as you pass by
which is quite unsettling the mystery of
what this prisoner thwomp did remains i
mean what did it do kill someone
actually i could believe that finally at
number one what happened to the other
princess zelda and i'm not talking about
the different princesses in between the
games that all existed hundreds of years
from one another i'm talking about the
one that link resurrects at the end of
zelda 2 the adventure of link see that
game is the sequel to the first legend
of zelda and is supposed to take place
four years or so after the original game
which ended if you'll recall with link
rescuing princess zelda from the
clutches of ganon but in zelda 2 link
saves another princess zelda that is
physically a lot older than the current
one but was kept in a state of stasis
and therefore didn't age from the point
where she entered that state you know
kind of like link from breath of the
wild what i'm saying is that quite
literally by the end of zelda 2 there
are two princess zeldas around the same
age in existence at the same time so how
did this work out exactly did they rule
as twins sisters did they trade off days
zelda 1 takes weekdays and zelda 2 takes
weekends and are there now two royal
families in the games that follow like
potentially breath of the wild depending
on which timeline it's in or did one of
them hide the other and make them
disappear quietly so that nobody would
ever know and therefore her reign would
not be compromised in history would only
record one princess at a time
who knows it's a mystery and speaking of
mysteries i was wondering if you'd be so
kind as to leave a like on this video if
you enjoyed it and if you would
subscribe if you learned anything new
and even if you didn't i hope you'll
consider subscribing anyway to stick
around it only takes a second and you
can always undo it later let me know
what you thought of this list in the
comments below and huge thanks as always
to my bandit crew who make my day every
day and enable me to continue making
videos for the internet to enjoy oh and
speaking of which if you don't feel like
joining up on a subscription you can
always buy me a coffee on my brand new
kofi page follow me on my socials linked
below and that's about all i've got for
this one this is bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
[Music]
you